[Music]
well hey everybody what's going on it's
Memorial Day so oops I forgot I still
have my so my lashes on and I've tried
to push my glasses close and they're
like like it's you know it's hard with
uh with all of this accoutrement you
know what I mean uh but yeah I forgot
that was on
so yeah it's uh it's Monday even though
it doesn't feel like it it feels like
Sunday again but here we are talking
about another episode of a haunting
which we watched last night now unlike
many episodes of Haunting this one
actually the title actually said what
happened in the episode
The Exorcism of Cindy sour you're like
yep right like it says on the tin yeah
that's exactly what happened in there it
wasn't that any of this [__] like
Echoes from the grave or yeah you know
calls from the attic or anything like
that you know what I mean it was it
wasn't vague it was telling you exactly
what the person's name was and I wonder
why they did that with this they never
do that I don't know like specifically
so um yeah I honestly I love it's kind
of hard to when I'm doing the um the
thumbnails for these episodes it's kind
of hard to like find good images because
there's really not I guess because the
show's so old or nobody really thought
about it it's kind of hard to find good
images
um from IMDb like IMDb will usually have
like one or two from each episode but
they're usually like not of the scary
[__] that's in the episode they're
usually like of the people like the
actors just like standing around doing
nothing which I don't understand why
that is but this one actually had a
really cool photo of uh you know the
demon-possessed Cindy or the actress
playing her like with her face all
[__] distorted you know what I mean
like I was saying the other day like
that sound garden video so I was like oh
[__] I gotta use that because that's the
only time like they actually had a good
photo of this [__]
um but yeah so Camp guy says my barely
five granddaughter turned around on the
playground and for a split second or two
I saw her exactly as she will be at
eight or nine as a girl I was gobsmacked
by the emotion I immediately manifested
oh that's so sweet that's so sweet
um yeah Camp guy said grandkids bring
out some really unique feelings I have
heard that I mean I've never experienced
that firsthand but I've heard that that
is the case so uh so yeah
this episode what did we think about
this episode Tom I think it was uh kind
of a samey kind of an episode a little
bit uh
the case was mostly just um witness
testimony and they didn't really witness
things moving or anything it was mostly
women other than like one thing yeah one
thing I think I threw a lug nut yeah
um but people were just talking about
how they fail
yeah I mean they saw things they saw
like um apparitions and several people
saw apparitions so I guess that's
something
you know what I mean yeah but not so
much like you said not so much
Poltergeist activity that file finally
he's going we're I'm uploading something
to the cloud video and uh yeah we were
we were shooting some [__] yeah and then
uh
it's got 12 minutes left so yeah that's
how you do it to Dropbox but for some
reason it my connection to the internet
says my connection to the cloud wasn't
that good we're on all kind of technical
issues oh you know what what I'm running
um YouTube in the other room oh let me
go go ahead go turn that [__] off man
why are you doing that all the time what
was the music I was listening that's
right
that's right that's right we had this we
had the synth wave going for the scene
we were shooting because we were
shooting a scene in there actually so we
like moved the lights in there and move
the lights back in here and stuff like
that and then the [__] up thing was
that we shot the scene and it was great
like you know we did like that we had
this whole scenario and like we were
doing it and then
um we were filming it with two cameras
but unfortunately the one camera that
had kind of the shitty angle like that
one recorded but then the other one that
had like the really awesome angle that
we wanted to keep um the camera like
dumped it like we lost the file so we
probably had to do it over oh yeah oh
well I mean and I was so mad because I
was like man that was so good too like
we totally did like we did a little bit
of rehearsal like because we knew what
the scenario was but then we were just
kind of like winging it and I was like
man this is coming out so good yeah um
yeah and then Tom's like [__] I lost the
[__] yeah I turned the camera off and
turned it back on and it asked me to
format reformat the [__] SD card
it does so it's a problem with that SD
card it's not the camera I mean like I
said we still have we still have the
file from another angle but the other
angle isn't as good yeah it's not good
enough to use it's not really I threw it
away did you really we can do that all
over again we have to do it all over
again but that's like so shitty because
I was like man this turned out so good
yeah oh well
well it's a good rehearsal I guess
that's what happens yeah and we like you
know we shot some other stuff too that
we can use so there's a there's that we
try to like not
waste anything right
well even even stuff that gets rejected
if there's a few four three or four hot
seconds in there we'll lift that out
we're gonna use that as [__]
basically teaser videos yeah maybe
something that runs so I like to think
that like we don't waste anything that
can be used like even if there's just
like three seconds of something like a
little in there yeah if it looks good
we're gonna use it but yeah and we and
we always do like photos and stuff do
you like overall like uh you know dress
up and everything
all right so uh this here was from
season five because we're working our
way through season five I think there's
only a couple left in season five uh
this was episode nine
I kind of remembered this one I actually
I remembered
um because the the mom in it she looks
like kind of the mom and the daughter
both kind of look like a little bit like
punk rock chicks yeah
um because the mom has like one piercing
right here because what's a word for
that well she has lived the one that's
like the Marilyn Monroe kind of thing
but it was it's blue though yeah like a
little beauty mark like a little beauty
mark like thing right there like on her
upper lip and then like the daughter had
two of them that were also like the same
color they were like a baby blue but
like the daughter whose name was
Chastity by the way also had like bright
pink hair and it was kind of all swept
over to one side so it's like very emo I
feel like of the time that this came out
because when did season five season five
was 2012 right yeah probably right yeah
yeah and um this happened in Georgia now
this happened in although I think um
when the when the story took place they
said it was 2010 so I guess it was a
couple years before they did the show
about it they did it this this place
called Social Circle Georgia like what
who named that town There's a town
called Social Circle Georgia evidently I
mean I know there's a lot of dumbass
like Town names but that's one of the
weirder ones I've ever heard Social
Circle Georgia Social Circle was hanging
out I guess so it's like there's like
five people there like having tea let's
name a town after ourselves all right so
that's what they did
so uh so yeah so as I said this took
place in 2010. and uh the mom's name who
obviously is Cindy
um now she's on there and she's talking
about you know she really loved uh
living in Social Circle Georgia it was
like a small town very typical like
Georgia small town southern small town I
guess
now uh at some point prior to the events
of this story prior to the paranormal
events
Cindy's husband dies now at first they
don't tell you how he dies but you find
out later on spoiler alert that he
actually
shot himself now I was led to assume I
don't think they ever said this outright
but I think they implied that he had
shot himself in that house that they
were living in because this wasn't a
case where they moved to a new place and
then oh [__] it's haunted you know what
I mean this was kind of I was led to
assume that they were in the same house
that they had been in when he killed
himself because I think they said later
on it's like oh we were thinking about
moving because this you know this house
had so many bad memories in it but they
couldn't afford it because obviously
what had happened was that when the
husband whose name was Jim I think he
was a mechanic and I guess he was the
one that was you know the main
Breadwinner in the family I'm assuming
like Cindy was kind of like a
stay-at-home mom type situation
and so when he committed suicide he
because he was like an alcoholic
although they don't know exactly why he
killed himself they didn't really go
into that all that much but um but so
when he died they were just kind of like
oh [__] like now we don't have any money
and we still have to like pay for this
house so Cindy actually worked as a
singer she was like in a band and I
guess she tore it around and I'm
assuming she made enough money to live
on at least I don't know what the real
house looked like I mean the one in the
episode was like
not something that you'd probably be
able to afford if you were just singing
in a bar band but you know maybe most of
it was paid for I don't really know but
yeah so that's what she did she sang it
it was like a blues and country band and
I guess she's saying it it wasn't just
at one place I guess she liked to work
around them so uh so yeah so that was
that and that was their main source of
income so like uh the daughter who like
I said she was like a teenager I don't
think they specified how old she was I'm
assuming like 16 17 something like that
and uh she was always like oh she wanted
to go see her mom perform but she wasn't
21 yet so she couldn't go
so pretty much like the first thing that
happened
as I said I don't think they just moved
into this house I think this was the
house that they had been living in and
presumably had not had any trouble with
you know prior to this
but apparently the mom she comes back
from like running errands like grocery
shopping or some [__] and she's in the
kitchen and she said she felt something
grab her from like two-handed and she
said she actually felt like hands on her
and she turns around thinking it's the
daughter like scaring the [__] out of
her like hey what are you doing you know
what I mean but then like no one's there
obviously
so yeah so like I said she just tries to
ignore it as they usually do from the
start
so um what happened not too long after
this is that Chastity is the daughter
she's in the kitchen like sitting at the
table like eating lunch or something
like that and she looks out the window
and sees a person like in the backyard
and she said he didn't look exactly like
her dad but gave her the impression that
that was her dad like standing in the
background like it kind of looked like
him but kind of different I will say and
I'm not sure what you know this is like
really sad because the Dude killed
himself and that's horrible but um the
dude that they have playing the dad in
The because you know he turns up as like
a ghost or whatever in the episode they
kind of made him look like a hobo which
I'm like
did he really look like a hobo in real
life did they just do that just because
she said he was an alcoholic I'm like
some alcoholics looked like they not all
alcoholics look like hobos you know it's
like you know what I mean so I thought
that was a little disrespectful that
they kind of made him look like a hobo
maybe he did look like a hobo I don't
really know but it's just like it did
seem like they made him look like a
stereo they're just trying to make him
look like scumbag well I guess they were
trying to make it so that like that when
you see his ghost it would be scarier
because obviously it would be scarier to
see like a hobo looking dude than like
just a regular looking dude I guess like
if you're seeing a ghost I don't know
but um yeah I was just kind of like I
was like that's kind of shitty that they
may just you know that's he had he had
problems you know what I mean don't make
the dude look like a bomb that's shitty
but yeah so she sees somebody in the
backyard that she thinks looks like her
dad and she
um you know because I guess they kind of
believed in the [__] and they were like
well you know maybe dad is still like
around like watching over us or
something like that so you know Chastity
kind of starts screaming though so like
the mom comes and looks but she doesn't
see anybody but she's curious about it
because Chastity says I'm pretty sure
like it looked like Dad you know what I
mean so Cindy goes out to look and goes
out to The Shed in the backyard which I
guess was kind of like where Jim used to
like hang out back in the day
and there's like a lug nut from her that
you know that was her husband's because
like I said he was a mechanic and it
kind of it's on the workbench and I'm
assuming the way she reacted like it
wasn't there before like it had come
from somewhere else I mean that was the
impression that I got the way she was
talking about it but it just kind of
like it started like shaking on the
table and then it like kind of pitched
itself at her not like it was trying to
hit her but trying to like get her
attention you know what I mean
so basically she thought she's like oh
well obviously Jim is still hanging
around
um you know and so she wasn't super
scared at first and she's like maybe
he's still watching over us and he's
trying to like get my attention so she
like starts talking to him it's like you
know oh me and you know me and Chasity
are doing fine and blah blah but just
because she's kind of nervous about it
she actually sends chess she's like why
don't you go stay at a friend's house
like until we sort out like what all
this weird ghost business is and like I
said they did talk about
wanting to move out of the house which
like I said was I presume the same house
where he killed himself
um but you know Cindy is still trying to
save money uh you know so they can't
afford to move yet so there's that
so over the next few months
to the program
things start to improve I guess at least
like in Cindy's social life and stuff
like that because she meets this guy
named Jason who was a former Pastor I
guess he's not a pastor anymore
but he used to be one I don't know what
he is now I don't think they said
so they start dating pretty seriously
now Jason also sees kind of a shadowy
figure out by the shed in the backyard
pulling pretty much the same place that
Chastity saw him earlier
so he's like oh well you know maybe it
was just somebody farting around in your
yard or maybe it was just a shadow or
something like that because it was kind
of like dusk you know what I mean like
they were out having a drink like on the
patio or whatever
later that evening they're actually like
sitting in the living room watching a
movie and then Cindy hears this weird
sound on the show it kind of sounded
like a breathy growling kind of noise I
guess like I'm not really sure how else
she would describe it
and then somebody knocked on the front
door and it was like supposedly like
really late at night because they're
like what the [__] why is somebody like
knocking on the door at this time of
night so Jason good he's like wolf I
better go check this out because you
know that's that's a job for a man right
so he goes and opens the door and
obviously nobody's there but they both
heard the knocking
and they both presumably heard that
weird breathy growling noise although I
think Jason said it's like oh maybe it's
your air conditioner I'm like I'm sure
she's lived here a long time I'm sure
she's pretty aware of what the air
conditioner sounds like but okay but the
thing about Jason in this one is that
because they interviewed the real guy as
well because he had been a pastor and
because he tells her later that he had
had some paranormal [__] happen to him
like too like when he was younger so he
was pretty immediately like on board
with stuff like he didn't he he didn't
go through this whole rigmarole where
he's just kind of like oh you're crazy
or you're just tired or whatever he
didn't go through that whole thing he
pretty much like believed her like from
the get-go which was kind of nice
so um at this point like after the
knocking and everything and Jason's like
huh that was really weird like there was
nobody there and then Cindy says well
I'm pretty sure and then she tells him
like about the stuff that's happened up
until then like about
um you know Chastity seeing the guy in
the backyard and like the lug nut and
everything and she's like I'm pretty
sure that my dead husband is haunting
the [__] you know what I mean and um and
maybe trying to like communicate with me
but like maybe he has something to tell
me so Jason like I said it's like oh you
know he's real into the Paranormal he's
like yeah I had some paranormal
experience as a child it's like I find
it really interesting
um you know so I so he thought it was
like pretty cool and so she apparently
also thought it was kind of cool
so she's like oh you know Halloween's
coming up maybe we should do like a
ghost hunt you know what I mean like go
out on some [__] ghost hunting thing
so that's what they decide to do
before that though the following night
or later the same night I'm not really
sure doesn't really matter
Chastity has this terrible terrible
nightmare which was very very realistic
about her father's death and in this
dream she basically sees his bum looking
ass sitting on this bed looking down
well it's like it's not my fault I'm
sure that I'm sure the real dude was
like a normal looking dude but it's like
the actor in this they really made him
look like a scuzz bag and I'm just like
well that's that's not cool
but yeah so he's like sitting on the bed
you know crying or whatnot like with the
with the gun in his hand and then in the
dream she sees that same black figure
like this evil looking black figure like
essentially kind of telling her dad to
like shoot himself you know what I mean
like or influencing him in that regard I
guess let me say something about the gun
okay because you guys know the [__]
we got good we got good uh [__] fans
in the show I was looking at the gun man
it looked like an old [__] Smith
Wesson like a 39 a 39-14 I think is what
they call her 39-15 like back in the 90s
the nine millimeter dual stack
semi-autos
I'm looking at it but it's like
three-quarter size
and I'm like man is that little 380 that
they made no it was a toy gun that they
painted up to look black and everything
it looked cool though but I was just
saying it just they didn't
they never shot the thing so they didn't
need to
they didn't need a plank fire yeah they
wouldn't really need yeah it's just this
is a haunting okay we're not doing like
a big Hollywood movie or we need like a
realistic type of [__] you got to keep
everything safe you had me confused for
a second though it looked real
but it was a uh it was a toy it was a
toy that was painted up a very accurate
toy of a Smith Wesson nine millimeter
automatic yeah because they didn't
actually they just kind of showed them
good and like putting his two head and
stuff I was impressed though I was like
man what model is that look like
oh that's a [__] toy
well if it full time then that's that's
pretty good for a few seconds yeah yeah
I mean the prop Department to the prop
Department you guys did a good job you
almost full-time it I think it was wrong
it was three-quarter size
and I'm going like nine there's nine
millimeter and there's 380 which is this
I guess you could say this the size
below nine millimeter and a lot of times
there is that three-quarter size Factor
going on if you go over 3A because you
don't need a lot of breach
but no it was a [__] toy
it's a [__] [__] toy yeah well you
know
so uh so yeah so Cynthia or Cynthia why
did I call her Cynthia I don't know
because I was thinking like the mom's
name is Cindy of Cindy but her name is
Chastity and I was like combining those
two things weirdly
so so yeah so Chastity like wakes up
screaming as you would I mean that's a
pretty traumatic dream to be having I'm
sure
um and Cindy is like when she goes in
there and finds out what's going on you
know she's like maybe we shouldn't be
staying in here like right now maybe we
should get she said there was this like
all night Diner like not too far away so
it's like they went there and like hung
out like over the night you know what I
mean
so at one point Cindy is out house
hunting because like I said they're you
know preparing to move at some point
when she has enough money saved and she
kind of gets lost and goes off on this
tangent and comes across this abandoned
house that was like super fascinating
and creepy almost like she was drawn
there it was like that kind of situation
so she's like oh my God you know how me
and Jason were talking about doing like
a ghost hunt this would be perfect
so she sends him a picture of it and
said hey this weekend we're gonna
explore this [__] it'll be like super
creepy and it'll be awesome
so that's what they do like that weekend
they come to this abandoned house which
I don't know like the logistics of this
because you know I know they do all the
urbex and all that kind of stuff but
it's just kind of like you just come
across a random abandoned house I don't
know if I'd be so head up about hey
let's just like go here and
get some flashlights and like hang out
in here like for the night you don't
know like who the [__] is squatting in
there you know what I mean but yeah so
they did that
so they come back and they have like
cameras and like a tape recorder they're
gonna try and like catch some Paranormal
Activity like going on in this creepy
ass place now they didn't say that they
saw this which and I know I say that a
lot like during these breakdowns
but there's like a shadow guy like
running around in the background like
behind them like while they're kind of
like with the flashlights and everything
there's like
a shadow guy run around the back like in
the bushes and stuff they didn't say
they saw that though so they're just
trying to like hint I guess that that's
what's going on
um and also like before they even go in
like Cindy hears a car pull up and she's
like oh [__] you know I mean like maybe
it's the cops or something like that so
she goes to check but there's nobody
there so it was like a sound like a car
motor but there wasn't anybody and then
they're like there was stuff like the
weird like a weird wind and like the
trees moving and like this cold breeze
and all this other kind of stuff and
like I said that shadow figure kind of
darting around which they actually kind
of I think they implied that they did
actually kind of see that or at least
saw what looked like maybe like a
shadowy figure kind of dark run of the
bushes and they said they felt like
whatever it was was like all around them
like it was like ready to jump out and
like pounce on them so they're like yeah
[__] this [__] um so you have to
understandably so then they run for the
car but then she says the thing which
I'm assuming she means the shadow thing
she said came at her like a train like
pal you know what I mean
so she Pops in the car they drive off
like you know peel out or as much as you
can on a dirt road
and then you know they drive a little
way down and then like he pulls over so
they can kind of like get their bearings
or whatever
and uh so when they stopped the car
Cindy is acting like possessed as hell
she is all like [__] growling and
like contorting and like hold the whole
[__] deal you guys know how it goes
like the whole possessive kind of thing
so you know hissing at him and whatnot
so Jason who is no slouch in this
department because he used to be a
pastor y'all so he knows how to deal
with demons that's for sure
so he pretty much immediately which is
so funny he just like immediately Twigs
onto the fact it's like oh she must be
possessed by a demon I know just what to
do so he just starts yelling at her tell
me your name tell me your name like he
starts yelling that at her
um and then so she's like start like
growling and hissing and whatnot and
then like in between all of that
possessive stuff
um she basically says help me you know
what I mean so yeah it's kind of like
that kind of deal so Jason starts
praying you know and tries to get Cindy
to pray too but she's trying she said
that she couldn't say the word Jesus
like she's just you know she couldn't
get it out because the demons like
making her not be able to say that sir
but then like finally she does and she
goes back to normal at least for a
little while because you know that
Demon's just kind of like hanging out in
there you know how that goes
now Cindy said that the next day she
felt like real hazy was the word she is
she said she felt really drained and her
daughter said that after this point she
started to become like a real [__] you
know I mean it was I mean because she's
like before that like her mom had been
really sweet and really nice and all
this other kind of stuff and now she's
just like really irritable and really
hostile and everything like that you
know Chastity comes in and she's like
hey I'm gonna go over to my boyfriend's
house or we're gonna go to the movies or
something like that I don't care what
you do get out of here yeah it was like
that you finished it which was like we
kind of laughed at that I don't care
what you do and she's like oh okay I'm
gonna take that and run with it so you
know she's a teenager
so uh so yeah
so she's like I guess she's kind of
going back and forth between like
possessy and normal right so she's kind
of like scared of what's happening so
she asked Jason to like stay over
but then she sees uh the shadow guy in
the yard and gets like all possessy
again like they're kind of sitting
outside like watching the stars or
whatever and he said that she was
sitting on the on the hood of the car
and she got like thrown backward and she
started acting all [__] crazy again
you know what I mean
and now she's convinced now that this
thing has been inside her I guess
um that this is the thing that made her
husband kill himself and now it's after
her that's what she has surmised from
this whole situation that this thing has
been in this house
prior to that and like she didn't see it
and I guess she thought that it was like
influencing him because she didn't know
why he killed himself that's what I'm
saying I think that they kind of implied
that
that she didn't know like the exact
reason yeah he's an alcoholic and stuff
like that but you know a lot of people
are alcoholics and they don't kill
themselves so there must have been like
something else going on and she didn't
know what was going on
so she started becoming convinced well
this is a demon or whatever and it made
him do that and now it's coming after me
because it's a dick you know what I mean
so um
so basically uh what happened after that
like I can't even read my own [__]
handwriting look at this [__] I got to
the bottom of the page and I was just
like you write in cursive though yeah
well gen Z doesn't know how to write
words I heard the Gen Z can't write nor
read in [__] curse well they probably
don't teach them they don't teach
anymore I learned it in third grade yeah
it was eight they made the Palmer method
yeah they had they gave you those
[__] long ass like pieces of paper
with all the with all the lines on it
like the two lines and then the dotted
line in the middle and you had to like
do it all
all nice and everything I have very nice
penmanship but the thing about it is
that well I was not so much here because
I'm trying to write fast even on me and
sometimes I go into like all caps
especially if it's something that like
somebody's saying
but yeah so um Jason like I said because
he's a former uh Pastor he's like again
he knows how to deal with this like
demon thing I've dealt with this before
don't worry I've got this handled
the demons
so basically she starts saying okay well
we need to get help though like we need
but I mean because he's dealt with it
before but he's like you know it's a
little above his pay grade apparently so
he's like we need to go to like you know
the church or whatever and apparently as
soon as he said that like we need to go
get some help from the church like her
voice gets all demony
and starts kind of like [__] with him
like uh you know saying all kind of like
horrible [__] about him and uh all this
other kind of stuff
so at this point they call not the
church they actually call uh some
paranormal investigators from Roswell
Georgia which I guess was like At first
was like a two-person team I think their
names were Michelle and I can't remember
like the dude's name Dan Dan so they
kind of show up
so they come to the house Michelle goes
into the bedroom and feels like real
creeped out in there
and then Dan has his little EMF meter
and there's like a huge big spike on it
and they said they got the impression
that there was an entity there that was
perhaps guarding something
so there was basically like when they
were doing the EVP sessions
they asked a question it's like oh if
you're here like make a noise and it
wasn't even on the EVP everybody
apparently heard that breathy growly
noise like from earlier so everybody
heard that so they're just like okay
well I guess it made a noise so there it
is
and then after that
um the guy Dan who's the guy with the
Eve with the EVP thing he says do you he
asked the ghost do you know that this is
Cindy's house this isn't your house
and at that point like Cindy gets
attacked again like she starts getting
thrown backward and thrashing about and
all that kind of stuff so
um and she said that
she was describing what this felt like
and she's basically like well she I
guess she was still knew that she was
her but this thing that was in her it's
like I really wanted to kill Dan like
the Paranormal Investigator like I just
wanted to jump on him and like [__]
kill him you know what I mean so I'm
assuming that was like the demon
so
um and she also she kind of like says
she wants to talk but the demon won't
let her
um you know so Demon's trying to like
pounce on the dude and everything like
that
now Dan supposedly weakens the entity's
control temporarily by I don't know what
he was doing but he was had a Bible so I
guess that's why
so well again kind of a Wimpy demon
gonna say all you gotta do is read a
page out of the Bible and it's like oh
no you know and everybody know and
everybody knows to do that we've all
seen the movies
come on up your game I'm just saying
damn but yeah so uh so yeah so he reads
the Bible at it and it's just kind of
like curses you know what I mean so it
kind of like goes inside Cindy somewhere
and doesn't pop out so
yeah it didn't pop out
shatter here's been with me because
something I should have pop out
you should pass out all the time you're
trying to Long stroke get get a good
camera angle
I know it's like well
everything we talk about is now now is
like porn related because it's
like usually like I said we just came
off like doing like a bunch of
he was just like thinking about that got
everything popping out
it's you know you gotta you got a demon
pop it out guess just waiting to see the
[__]
a little Aaliyah really yeah she's like
oh I wanted been wanting to do only fans
and I said well I'll send you some
samples and [__] okay
might be able to [__] collab weather
because they do that because she can't
do it she can't do her own edits
yeah you know doesn't have doesn't have
any equipment either well I made a bunch
of little um I made like a bunch of
little teaser videos yeah well they're
not teasers they're they're shitty
they're x-rated but I mean they're but
they're short yeah like some I think the
longest one is like a minute and six
seconds or something like that that's
good you need that for only fans that's
how you that's what I'm saying because
they're all fishing videos right right
getting tips and [__] it's like I cut
little bit like shorter bits out of the
longer ones and like and then like we
shot some stuff that like a lot of it we
couldn't use because like the ankle was
[__] up but there was like seeing that
stuff in there that I could use yeah you
use it it's only like a few seconds you
use those to sell bigger videos right
so so that's what we're doing
so uh so yeah so while the entity is
weakened by a page out of the Bible like
was Michelle who's the other Paranormal
Investigator she says to Cindy I'm
afraid that you need an exorcism because
you know it's right there in the title I
mean you knew she was gonna need an
exorcism at some point
so that night Jason stays over
and he's
this was kind of funny because like so
he's in bed but he's like all he's
trying to be like slick and he's laying
over on his side and he's like praying
like in like all sneaky like he's like
like that you know what I mean like so
she can't see him but she's laying over
there like on her back and she you know
the demon knows what he's doing
obviously so she does the demon boy stop
praying you know what I mean she does it
like that and he says I'm well I'm not I
don't know what you're talking about
it's that kind of situation
and then we okay we laughed at this
because then she says like some weird
ass [__] right like some [__] that
sounds like another language
and Jason legit like the real guy he
legit comes out and says oh I recognized
it as Aramaic I'm like [__] yeah you
did not yeah who the [__] just knows
enough Aramaic and it's like oh I know
exactly what that said he went to
Harvard to learn Aramaic I'm not saying
that people don't know Aramaic they do
I'm just saying that I find it very hard
to believe that this [__] this guy like
knew so was so familiar with Aramaic
that he immediately like knew what that
phrase meant that she said I'm just like
not buying it that's what I'm saying you
know if it was French or something like
that fine like you know that's fine
because a lot you know that's millions
and millions of people speak that but
I'm just saying Aramaic meh I'm not
buying it even if it was Latin
even if it was Latin I would buy it
Aramaic not so much but apparently what
he says yeah it recognized it as Arabic
um
and what the phrase was according to him
and like I'm sure nobody checked so he
could just like whatever make it up was
your God bows to me
I'm like clearly not because you don't
even like you just read a page out of
the Bible and you just get all for
clamped about it so it's like you know
it must be he's yeah you're God's not
bound to nobody so yeah
also
um at this point
Cindy she looks in the mirror like they
kind of skip ahead to like a different
scene and she's like looking in the
mirror and it's kind of a situation
where you remember in the Amityville
Horror where like Margot Kidder like
looked in the mirror and she was like an
old lady yeah yeah you remember that
yeah that was a good scene actually yeah
it was kind of like that like her face
didn't look like old lady face like
necessarily but she looked kind of
[__] up but her hands look like old
lady hands and I was like oh look they
went to Spirit Halloween and got like
some of those really long like Black
Talon fingernails so she was wearing
those like oh that's how they showed
that she was like demon possessed she
had like old looking hands with big
[__] Spirit Halloween nails on them
so there we go
um also her head like kind of starts
flopping around like
you know what I mean like that's your
standard issue like possession kind of
uh situation
so Jason starts praying again and the
entity let's go for a bit like I said so
he can't be that powerful I'm just
saying
so they're like okay well the priest is
on the way you know they call the priest
and he's going to come out there and
he's going to take care of the situation
probably but before that Cindy is
getting like super nervous about it's
like I don't want to do this I don't
want to do the exorcism and all this
other kind of [__] and then she started
saying like the real woman she actually
started saying I felt like like before
the priest was getting there I guess he
was like on the way there and route
and she's like I felt like I wanted to
cut my leg open
like yeah she said that she wanted to
like stab herself in the leg and just
like see what was inside there or
something like that so I'm like yeah
that's that's an issue
so uh so yeah
so then uh the priest and the team and
everything like that they show up and I
actually wrote down this dude's name his
name was Reverend Darren Simpson and one
other person whose name I didn't catch
like I said I try to write this down
like really quick because I hate to kind
of stop and like back it up every few
seconds so I just try to write really
fast I should probably learn shorthand
is what I should probably do but you
know one of these days because that
would probably be a lot easier
so Michelle said uh that she senses the
presence of evil which you know sure
and um they're kind of the thing about
it is that I guess Cindy is still in the
house at this point but like everybody
else like Jason and the paranormal team
and everything like that like they went
outside like to meet the priest because
he was showing up so they're all outside
and Michelle said oh I felt like maybe
we shouldn't go inside like something
really bad would happen and then they
hear this big loud crash from like
inside the house so they all kind of run
in there and this was actually a pretty
funny I mean it would be terrifying if
it happened in real life but it's like
funny to see it like in a thing so they
walk in the house and Cindy is just like
[__] doing gymnastics like all over
the [__] like you know what I mean just
like on the couch like she's going to
like kind of tumbling from the from the
couch to like the couch arm and then
like back again and like like that and I
was just like wow crazy so it's you know
like I said if you really saw that in
real life you probably [__] your pants
but like when you see it like in a
reenactment you're just kind of like
okay it's just like I'm like look at her
go see just tumbling around everywhere
so she also said at this point that she
wanted to kill Jason her boyfriend so
you know hatred fills up the room that's
what the narrator said so that that'll
happen
and then after this like I didn't even
like write down all the stuff because
this is just standard exorcism yada yada
you see this at the end every day put
her in a chair and like tie her down and
like the Lord blah blah and like you
know put the thing and she's screaming
and hissing and all that nonsense
uh so at the end they basically give her
what does that say the holy water what
oh holy wafer okay
they've never tried that on one of these
shows yeah because I was thinking that
for a second I'm like wait what did they
put it where did they put the holy water
you're probably water edema well you
know getting the demon out from the
inside out that's that's how you gotta
do they do that in the Medieval Era a
lot that's what I'm saying so there's
you know so there is a precedent there
is a precedent for that we didn't just
make that up but they did do that kind
of crap back then I mean you know the
medieval people what did they know it's
like they're always the one to stick
stuff up each other's butts they're
crazy
eating dead stuff that they're found on
the side of the road yeah making people
smell dead stuff
although to be fair some people actually
still do yeah
it tastes terrible try it which is a
shitty thing to do to somebody don't do
that but um but yeah so not holy water
anime would be much funnier but no they
actually just give her the holy wafer
because they're like okay well that's
how you know because after the exorcism
is over that's how you know if it worked
or not that's like the test they're like
here have this cookie it's vanilla wafer
for sure it's not like not really they
didn't really do that but he's like yeah
it's a holy wafer and it's like then she
starts like
she's like gagging and stuff so they're
like well [__] it didn't work so we
gotta do it again so you know priest
[__] it up the first time didn't work
so uh so yeah we got to do it again now
there's also like during this whole
exorcism situation and again nobody said
they saw this specifically but there's
that black shadow dude like moving
around
um and everybody kind of felt super cold
and maybe the demon trying to get into
somebody else because I think one of the
other paranormal teams said it's like oh
I felt somebody standing next to me or
somebody was like coming at me or some
[__] like that
um and then at this like Cindy they said
she looked like super [__] up like she
had like really cloudy milky looking
eyes and um just acting like an animal
basically which you know like like I
said standard exorcism type stuff and
then you know the priest
Reverend uh Darren I think is his name
and he's just all you know asking what
the Demon's name is and [__] like that
and then finally it seemed like it
wasn't that hard to get the name out of
him you know what I mean it's just but I
didn't catch the name
did they say it because I mean the way
that they talk they act like they said
it but I was like if they did I didn't
catch it the name of the demon
I said Bruce uh yeah
Stephanie I don't know
Stephanie the demon
[Laughter]
yeah I mean one that everybody
recognized they're like oh [__] that's
bad right oh yeah that one yeah I know
that one they can't just like or they
have to make up something that sounds
that sounds bad you know does it says
ill
[Laughter]
asteroth yeah that was one that I just
saw in the um episode of Thriller yeah
he was like praying it's just saying
those names and nothing just reminds me
of being a kid
listen to Venom albums all right then it
was like it was one of them they they
[__] invented the black metal genre
it was like it was a lot like Motorhead
it was good music I liked it uh but it
was they had the satanic Motif okay
and you run out of [__] you know so they
were just yeah you do run out right but
[__] so limited as that yeah the dude
that uh the dude that was Kronos was the
main singer actually his name was Conrad
lent [__] nice British guy
[__] ended up [__] getting jacked
and [__]
but he I saw an interview with him
because a lot of the [__] would kind of
scaring me coming off of [__] seeing
a poltergeist when I was a kid and
[__] having a religious background
I thought maybe they believed in this
but I saw an interview with her later on
YouTube because you couldn't didn't have
YouTube when I was growing up so you
didn't have access to these people and
uh he was like it's so funny you know
I'm doing this people are asking me if
I'm sacrificing virgins and [__]
killing babies no this is I don't
believe any of this [__] man it's it's
like you you watched the Evil Dead and
and I saw the Evil Dead and this is the
albums that we came up with it's just
you know totally creative Endeavor
that's for me it's like people taking
pictures oh yeah especially in the
United States
that was during the satanic Panic yeah
we did a whole couple shows about that
yeah it was just it was just a band that
had a horror theme yeah yeah that's all
it was but it's funny because you know
they used all the [__] real cliche
demon names a lot you know I could well
like I said you have to you you want to
go with ones that are slightly obscure
but you still wanted to be kind of
recognizable so people like oh I've
heard about that you know what I mean oh
comrade did his [__] did his research
I'm sure he read that was that the
families
yeah
which which is hammer and all that which
now that was a real book so yeah all
those [__] Renaissance
he must have read all that because he he
could name all the damn demons and yeah
putting even [__] [__] he had the
names of [__] Greek Titans in there
you know takes it all up he had it all
in there just anything that was old and
powerful and bad you know it was it
wasn't Kronos the father of Zeus yeah
yeah he was eating all of his [__]
wives children from becoming the Gods
and eventually Zeus [__] survived the
cannibalism and [__] don't eat me dad
I think cut his balls off and then
killed him I think I think he actually
uh yeah it was something like that I
think he's a lot of that going on in
ancient mythology yeah yeah in those
days uh to overthrow your dad you had to
cut his balls off that was just what you
did yeah that was the rules which is
probably what happened that's probably
what happened to Moses
uh no not yeah no no no no it's probably
what happened to Noah in the nose story
what was his son Kane I think it was
Kane no no what was this episode
uh uh did it wait the one this one that
said that did he whip naked and they
banished him right
[__] Dr Price said was Noah the one
that had Shem ham and yeah it was ham I
think one of them sham ham and one of
the sons
one of his sons saw him naked and
covered up his nakedness and then they
cast him out for that
all right he's like what you wanted to
just hang it out for everybody to see I
was just put a blanket over the
[__] Dr Price I could punish
forever for that we've had Dr Price on
the show before he he does not believe
that's what it was originally what he
thought is he thought that I think it
might have been ham
um
or was it Kane
no but see Kane wasn't yeah it was done
though yeah it came was pre-dates all
that yeah yeah he was like yeah he was
Adam and Eve's right what they think
really happened was I think it might
have been ham
the ham
cut Noah's balls off see that makes more
sense to me because that's everybody
would be like what the [__] and you're
like what do you mean you try to take
why would that happen it's because in
older stories to overthrow a god-like
demigod the sun had to cut the dad's
balls off therefore he's no longer a man
you can now take his throw right you're
like taking his mask you're taking his
mask and then he's there for his he
could no longer rule
and uh which means that if that's what
it originally said they'd cut that out
because it was probably a dead giveaway
that all of these dudes were
mythological like all the other myths
yeah they had to change the [__] up they
had to change it up because they stole
stuff from like all the older religions
they're like well let's change it a
little bit so everybody knows that we're
like you know it's a copyright violation
yeah it's a copyright violence if we
leave the whole ball cutting game
they'll know that we're talking about
the Greeks and all the other stories
yeah because that's a very and we've
already proclaimed all those other
stories as Legends and [__] so we
have mythology so we've got to get that
out of there but they didn't do a real
good job of it because they're still
like all these lingerings a lot of
Mythology in there there's a lot of
lingering stuff in there that doesn't
make any sense unless you go back and
look at like the original mythology that
inspired it yeah like just there's a lot
of [__] who was the dude that had all
the hair
um all the red hair Samson no
Samson was dude with all the hair all
the red hair uh you know the guy with
the hair and the Ishmael know what was
this [__] anyway what what they're
actually alluding to and there's a bunch
of details Dr Price talked about what
they're talking about as an old solar
God the red hair and the hair all of his
body is the golden red sun rays of this
of of another God is what they're
talking about so all the old gods that
the Hebrews believed or the Jews the
Jews believed in had been demoted into
demigods and and guys that were men of
great renown
but they used to be Gods because it was
a Pantheon like the Greek sure and yeah
but you know they couldn't have that
anymore it's like no no there's just one
no you can't throw that story out okay
we'll reboot it as this is a [__]
descent story so good yeah you will
reboot it is that this guy is is a
descendant to [__] of [__] Noah
and we'll include it look okay well I
kind of feel like too they were probably
like really lazy they're like well these
are good stories and it's like we're too
lazy to like rewrite our all our own
[__] so let's just like you know
retrofit some of these stories but we'll
just change them enough so people will
be like ooh like it's all new you know
what I mean so it's that kind of thing
uh yeah John Gore says Engelbert that's
the name of it that's the name of the
David
Engelbert Humperdinck there's a whole
because I know Tammy's here and she's
like real into Eddie is already he does
like a whole [__] funny thing about
Engelbert Humperdinck because I don't
know if you know but that's not his real
name yeah I think they're like and it's
like that's why he did like a whole bit
where he was just like I'd love to put a
fly on the wall like during that meeting
were they like it's because he had a
norm he had like a normal name and like
so he comes up with this because a lot
of his stuff is um like improvisational
so he comes up with this whole like long
list of like all these [__] crazy
names that they came up with before that
and it's just like I can't remember all
of them but it was like super super
funny but yeah so Engelbert the demon
um so yeah so Reverend Darren Darren
right yeah Dan was the Paranormal
Investigator guy I'm getting confused
with all the D names I think they said
maybe they said the Demon's name was
Ammon right because that's a demon
that's a demon name right maybe I guess
that's kind of was I don't know it was
something like that so he pretty he
gives up the name like pretty easily
he's a pretty weak ass demon he's gonna
say so uh so the Reverend is like so now
they can tell him to leave by name you
get out of here that's basically what it
is so uh yeah that was easy like Yay she
didn't kill anybody or slap anybody or
she didn't even do anything she just
like the demon just left and then they
were just kind of like oh you know
everything was lighter brighter presence
of God smell of sanctity whatever they
didn't say that but I said that I added
that bit
um but yeah
they said so yeah the Demon's gone but
the Reverend warns
it might come back though
implying that it's like you're not
living right then the demon might come
back so none of that whoring around or
like you know playing with Ouija boards
or watching horror movies or any of that
or the demons gonna come back and it's
going to be your fault that was that was
what I that was what I heard anyway
that's not what he said but that's kind
of what I heard
so uh so father Darren actually blesses
the house where he goes including the
shed where the lug nut situation
happened
and uh also you know calls on Saint
Michael hey protect the place yada yada
and then Cindy says that maybe that her
husband's ghost was like watching over
them and maybe that that's why like
um Chastity had seen him a couple times
like maybe he was like hanging around to
like more than hey there's a demon in
the [__] that like killed me so you
might want to watch out for that but I
don't know if that's the case or not
because I don't think at least from what
they said that they didn't see the dads
ghost after that
so uh after this they're just like well
you know even though the house
is presumably okay to live in now
they're like eh you know it's just too
many bad memories so they actually do
sell the house and move away and uh they
said as a little Coda at the end they
said Chastity still has nightmares about
her dad's death but has kind of learned
to deal with them so everything is
probably okay now so there's that
John Gore said it was kind of like
Zeppelin with Tolkien yeah yeah yeah
with their words which is funny because
Led Zeppelin is like you know and even
nowadays like people like you know
consider them like really cool and stuff
like that when you listen to the lyrics
I'm like oh my God like back in the day
it has been so nerdy it's still kind of
nerdy but it's out it sounds cool though
back in the day at least Americans
didn't know what he was talking about
that's true they did they weren't
reading token token wasn't
wasn't a known quantity back in the 70s
or 80s it really when that [__]
that first um
Lord of the Rings movie came out the
animated one the room the rotoscope yeah
I love that one I want to say I did too
I did too
um that just appeared and people were
blown away they're like what is this
you know only nerds
into the [__] Dungeons and Dragons
and [__] [__] in role-playing games
knew what Tolkien was
they read that but the mainstream didn't
read it I think well I mean you were
reading it yeah my boys were like a
military academy back in the [__]
early 80s reading the [__] out of toke
and I did too when I was looking at
dragons it wasn't my main thing because
I'm more a horror girl than like a
fantasy person but I did read all of
that you know what I mean I read like
Lord of the Rings and The Hobbit and all
of that when I was younger I don't think
I ever read the Lord of the Rings I read
The Hobbit Lord of the Rings uh [__] and
I saw all the uh the movies you know the
the animated movies yeah yeah we saw
those recently uh they're pretty good
they're not as good as I remembered them
but I really like the Lord of the Rings
that one was kind of like a Frank
Frazetta yeah moving Frank was at a
movie kind of it was kind of like Fire
and Ice but darker
remember we just reviewed the hobbit not
too long ago didn't we ever so we
watched it just like a few months ago
didn't we yeah I don't remember if I
thought we'd reviewed it right it's got
It's got all of them it's got like the
uh uh Return of the King and all that I
think they I think there's like four of
them in there
hmm I don't remember yeah I think
there's more of them than that
I want to see that I want to see uh Lord
of the Rings again the the old Lord of
the Rings The Animated one the animated
one yeah yeah yeah we should probably
because I thought we watched it around
that same time that we watched The
Hobbit but I guess we did
it was rotoscope it looked like really
good cartoon animation
Tammy says the movie Tolkien was pretty
good oh I remember seeing the um
previews for that and we never got to
see it said he had a pretty rough start
in life
yeah I don't know a great deal about his
biography but yeah I had actually wanted
to see that movie because I remember
seeing the um trailers for that like a
long time ago but one of these days I'll
get around to it like I said it's gonna
be like so many [__]
so many movies I gotta see so many books
I gotta read Never Gonna live long
enough Jesus Christ you know well you
know I mean I guess that's good I'll
never get bored you know but it's like
I just I have so many I just like had
this huge huge list
but yeah so uh not that I don't see like
a lot of comments what are you is
anybody commenting on the [__]
I'm I'm actually looking at other
messages they're right there I know that
but I'm just I wondered if yours had
updated because mine didn't update
because sometimes it didn't update which
always kind of worries me but yeah so
that was that haunting episode it was
you know what it was a pretty good
episode it was a pretty good episode but
it's a pretty standard exorcism
narrative I didn't really get the sense
that
it wasn't one of those ones because you
know how a lot of times when you see one
where there's like a you know culminates
like in a big exorcism at the end you
get a sense that it's almost kind of
like Christian propaganda type thing
because it's like the people are like
super super religious you didn't really
get that sense in this one they didn't
really seem super jesusy or anything
so I don't know I and I guess the
implication was that she had picked up
this demon at this abandoned house that
they went ghost hunting at I mean that
was
pretty sure that's what the implication
was because they kind of made a big deal
about her going to this abandoned house
and her kind of like just finding it
randomly and being like almost like ooh
like she was drawn to it you know what I
mean so it was like the demon being like
hey come here this is where so the demon
lived in the abandoned house I guess and
was just waiting for some sucker to come
by to possess I'm guessing that's kind
of what's going on I don't know how
demons work but that's basically what
was going on all right so yeah that was
that was all of that episode so what
else would we like to talk about now
that we're done talking about a haunting
yeah I thought you were asking
it now well I mean I'm asking everybody
turkey down there says
I thought you wanted a salad we haven't
eaten all day today I have not eaten a
single thing you actually you ate uh a
small Debra although actually this one
is kind of like a medium-sized Deborah
because it's one of those peanut butter
yeah what is it what are they called it
was the uh it's like an oatmeal cream
pie but it's like a peanut butter one
yeah two peanuts with peanut butter in
the middle is good I just I I love those
but I can't eat them because I looked at
the calorie count I'm like holy [__]
that's like 450 calories should be one
that's like a [__] meal also I can't
eat it but yeah he ate one of those but
I haven't eaten a single thing today so
starving but yeah he made a turkey yeah
so we're gonna go home I had that thing
it's like a smoked turkey it's not a
Christmas turkey
it's just it I put Liquid Smoke on it
slow cooked it it's almost falling apart
yeah it's been in there all day it's
good so it's just gonna be good with
like a make like a salad yeah bought
that last Thanksgiving I got them 60
cents a pound you just can't beat that
no it's 11. yeah I think I think we've
said that a bunch of times like we went
to Publix like a bunch of times yeah you
could only buy two like per person so
it's like he'd buy two and I'd buy two
and then we go back the next day
I still got five of them in the freezer
down there
yeah Tammy says ooh I found this
Snickerdoodle Little Debbie he's pretty
good yeah I like that one yeah yeah yeah
we've had the Snickerdoodle ones oh yeah
yeah that's right yeah yeah but the
peanut butter ones they're harder to
find like they have them at Publix but
they don't always have them but like I
said they're bigger significantly bigger
and thicker and they're like really
because you know your regular Little
Debbie it's not you know it's probably
like 200 300 calories something like
that but the peanut butter ones are like
450 so that's like a meal replacement as
well as I'm concerned well there's two
oatmeal pot cream pies too there's the
small one and then there's the big one
it's the size yeah that's true it's yeah
it's big but it weighs about twice that
yeah it's like super thick and dense but
they're really good I still want to try
what was the double fudge oh you called
it fudge round fudge round see I don't
like those you might like them I mean
they're not terrible but your chocolate
cookie with chocolate frosting right
they've had those forever and because
they had those when I was a kid I'm
surprised you hadn't had one because he
got star crunches and I was like Star
Crunch is good it's like a hundred
thousand dollar bar like 100 Grand yeah
I don't like those I'll eat them too
like if that's all that's around but
it's never my first pick I'm not really
I'm not really into the star crunches
for whatever reason but yeah so um I
guess we'll yeah wrap it up so we can go
have some turkey and go watch some more
oh and also I over the weekend I bought
the entire series of Night Gallery so
because if you guys follow me over on
the scare Salon Channel and blog I've
been I did the pilot like I'm still
doing Thriller but I'm watching those on
YouTube
but we were at FYE in the mall on
Saturday and they had all of the Night
Gallery like in one big pack for like 34
and I was just like oh [__] I'm gonna
get because I was gonna do the whole
series and I don't know where else to
find them so I just bought them So
eventually I don't think I'm gonna do
because like if you've been watching
Thriller like I usually do like six
episodes at a time I'm probably not
gonna do that I might just do like two
or three episodes at a time because I
don't have a lot of time but I have been
watching them uh at night I already did
the pilot but I'm gonna do season one so
I watched a few last night but I fell
asleep so I'm gonna watch other ones but
yeah look out for that like I'll be
posting those
intermittently you know what I mean so
uh so yeah so hopefully you guys enjoyed
this paranormal uh shenanigans that
we've been talking about on here uh you
know again decent episode but it's
exorcisms so it's just pretty standard
as far as that goes so uh yeah we'll be
back again on Wednesday
for the main show and the topic for
Wednesday's show is
Patty Hearst oh her okay all right yeah
so we're gonna be talking about Patty
Hearst which I've been putting that in
the poll along to a long time but
but yeah it's funny because I first
started reading about her like back in
the 80s because of that camper van
Beethoven's on which is called Tanya
which is like about her but yeah so
we're gonna be talking about that on
Wednesday so hopefully you guys can all
come and see us then and uh so yeah we
will see you guys on Wednesday night
good evening